and loves you with Oliver I to go the
letter o new home we're home to us we
will welcome her with open arms
it's time for roses and road
[Applause]
everybody it's me Lauren Zima and Favre
is crying about Hannah and yes we just
finished apart one of the two nights
live bachelor finale and we are here to
talk about it all first of all I want to
tell you of course I have rosacea
champagne so let's see how popping this
OnLive goes Oh
Kelsey I'm sorry I'm a pro yeah crushed
it
that's the sportiest thing I've ever
done okay everybody Cheers through the
tears that was the theme of this evening
wasn't it yep we had a lot of crying
relationships dying and me doing
exasperated sighing I want your comments
and questions we've been getting some in
already on our Instagram story and on
our youtube page keep them coming
because so much to discuss everyone yes
do you think it's gonna be Hannah Ann do
you think it's me Madison she kazumi had
a B wasn't Hannah P we know that now
Hannah and I had a beef okay so we had a
momma meltdown a madison maddening and a
hannah and holding on
she's just trying isn't she she's like
Peter you give me something man I've
been so unproblematic champagne gate
wasn't even really my fault could you
give me something what do you guys think
should Peter go with Hannah and right
now we are already seeing that Madison
is going to make a return per the ending
trailer we're gonna get into it all
right let's back it up so you know what
I need a drink hmm and that's just
that's not gonna be enough is it now so
let's do the right thing
did Peter that's a question did barb
that's a bigger question yep a lot of
you talking about whether barb pushed
too hard let me know in the comments
below I think so anyway
still on barb but man oh man she was she
was pushing that baby right along wasn't
she pushing that little bud beater using
her tears like a river to just push him
further down into the rapids she was
saying go
go towards love I don't know if you'll
drown on the way but going my tears I do
love barb also uh shameless plug I do
want to say that I've been posting some
older interviews up on my Instagram and
very interestingly barb has held true
you know she might not be right with how
hard she's pushing her son but she has
stayed consistent and we 11 on brain
moment okay all right so first of all
everybody Peter sees his family finally
now I know that Peter has been judged
for being indecisive all season long and
I've been saying I think it's because
he's been without mom and dad yes this
man is a pilot gainfully employed in his
late 20s but he's still been living at
home and I think when you live with mom
and dad you rely on them whether it's
good or bad you know
so now Peter is with his parents and we
are going to see some serious
decision-making aren't we
by the way wait for this you guys
playing for this we got graphics
happenin live
don't drink every time somebody called
Peter bud she's not there for you but
but but you know what but you know maybe
deep in your heart but you knew that oh
wow that champagnes fizzy isn't it I got
a complaint these are so fun was this
episode I thought it was great TV let me
know and the comments below looks like a
little friend I'm not alone Peter is
okay anyway so oh yes Peter alone in his
principles alone and his thoughts his he
alone in the end we don't know so barb
she calls Peter bud she also did quite a
lot of crying this episode don't drink
for every time we saw barb sobbing
hugging her son no i-i've never seen a
woman cry and then recovers so quickly
so fast she's like up and I'm good yeah
wipe those tears are right away and I'm
gonna tell you how I feel now first
Hannah Ann met the family are still in
Australia
Hanna Anne and Madison are remaining and
they both are gonna meet Peters family
and they're here so Hanna Ann comes
along and that's Madison but Hanna Ann's
gonna be there and Hanna Ann is already
crying herself wasn't this interesting I
very quickly was thinking Oh Barb's
gonna connect with this gal because
they're both Criers and that's exactly
what happened isn't it
you know why let's go ahead and do it
don't drink for every time Hanna and
cried this is like real for me don't get
that in return you know this could be
like you know our last week together
I said don't drink anyway
so Hanna Ann is doing a lot of crying
she's doing a lot of hugging oh oh I
guess not shake another drink mm and
barb tells Hanna Ann and Peter that they
are reminding her of her and Peter
senior now that's a telltale comment
from mom isn't it she's literally
looking at them saying oh you remind me
of us me and my husband of 30 years and
her beautiful successful marriage look
how we're holding each other look how
you're holding each other we've got two
wonderful children and that's exactly
what I want for my firstborn Peter Peter
jr. is even his name Peter senior and
Peter jr. and Hannah and you are me
that's what barb said so I think we all
knew what was Barb's feeling on the
situation but she hadn't met Madison yet
still I also was happy to see that we
now know where Peter gets his 747
statements from you guys here is barb
talking about the best feeling her
mother can have I can feel the love that
she has for my son and
that speaks volumes to me just it's it's
the best feeling a mother can have
uh-huh
that's a 747 barb I don't know if this
is a 747 I don't know how accurate our
balloon plane purchasing on the Amazon
Prime was but here it is and I love it
festive for the finale okay so we now
know Peter gets his emotional side and
his definitive side from mama and that's
okay
I mean it's confusing sometimes but it's
not the worst thing
next up Peter comes in with a 747 here's
Peter talking about Hanahan there's
truly nothing there that I'm liking I
promise you there's nothing there's
nothing there that he's lacking nothing
so why wouldn't you just why wouldn't
you know what okay here's why here's why
Peter doesn't just pick Hannah and then
and there you guys because Peters now
staying consistent Peter as we know
doesn't want easy he wants crazy yes yes
yes yes and crazy can mean up and down
you know it doesn't mean that Madison is
crazy it just means a roller coaster
because Peter literally said that one of
the women had been easy and Anne and the
other had not Madison okay
Oh what did you think at this point a
lot of question marks the questions
would only get more intense oh and your
questions are coming in oh gosh oh gosh
oh we have so many I'm so sorry a lot
happening oh well technology Oh barb is
the villain I disagree Billy I don't
think Barb's the villain this is what's
interesting here is I'm getting your
your questions but it's like they're
being sent to me and I'm receiving them
so whoever's hearing this are conformed
very confusing so Liz that at least
Hannah Ann is actually crying at an
appropriate mom at this time that's fair
although I don't think Hannah Ann was
the biggest crier of the season then we
have Carolyn saying at this point you
could end up with anyone yes Carolyn and
we'll get into all that
do you still admire barb Lisa says I'm
over her I do still admire barb because
I think that at her core barb is just a
parent who loves her child and that
she's motivated by that
like how Peters been motivated by his
heart this whole time he's been saying
that and I think he's been consistent on
that like yes maybe they're not making
the best and wisest decisions but we
were looking back at what they did you
know hindsight's 20/20 when you're in
the moment yeah barb got a bit intense
CSCS yes she did Cheryl cheers to you
Cheryl a bit intense is the best
possible way to put that wool drisdom
says barb is my idol well Tristan okay
I'm gonna go partying with you it's
gonna be wild all right Oh Taylor says
Lauren you've been the best part of the
season Taylor thank you but where would
I be without the show I love it so much
all right let's get back to things and
more of your comments we'll come in
later so things go easily with Hannah an
easy breezy beautiful Amazon model girl
she's in some Amazon ads if you guys
missed that very sweet and next up we
have Madison so Madison comes in and she
talks to Peter about the past she comes
in hot right away and says I'm still not
good I'm still frustrated about you know
how things went with us after I told you
that I didn't want you to sleep with
other people and Peter straight-up calls
it what I've been calling it you guys on
ultimatum and yes when I interviewed
Peter after the women tell all
he kind of backed up on what he
apparently would wind up saying he said
at that time oh I don't think was an
ultimatum well guess what Peter in the
moment you did and I just saw it here
tonight so I'm gonna cheers to myself
because I was right just by definition
it's an ultimatum people and what I also
appreciated was that Peter said he
thought it was a good thing that Madison
gave him that ultimatum yes that's what
I've been saying
ultimatum czar necessarily bad they are
just clear and we want clarity even if
it's not what we want to hear anyway so
they kind of have a bit of a resolution
there and what I do love about you know
when Peter gets just even the tiniest
bit of resolution is that he's 747s it
again here's what Peter said after he
and Madison had that
minor talk I can honestly like I don't
have any concerns I have zero worries
yeah you heard it he has got zero
worries okay let's get a few more of
your comments in here oh I'm sorry I'm
supposed to go from the Instagram
stories Sarah do you think Peters
parents had too much influence on Peters
journey what an interesting question
Sarah I think probably the biggest
question of the night and I will say yes
I think that mom got too emotional
I liked the Peter called barb out for it
a little bit he said you got to stop
this mom you are sobbing and telling me
what to do with the biggest decision of
my life you can't do that mom you know
what because he might even hold that
against you later mom so you just gotta
let him figure it out himself but again
I understand that barb is coming from a
place of deep love for her child and she
just wants to protect him but yes I do
think that barb did too much and
obviously Peter did he called her out in
the moment still left barb though
alright so Peter has zero worries but
his family does don't they yeah a big
shout out to peter's little brother jack
younger but i think why sir
he was like uh hey man you're like
pretty physical in relationship so she's
not kind of a sick thing yeah jack thank
you for being the voice of the people
and Peter's parents are very honest with
him and with Madison saying Madison
seems pretty religious you're spiritual
but not that religious and here's what
Peter had to say about compromising
himself yes we are very different in
lifestyle and what I like to do on
weekends but what I do know is that we
both acknowledge that we are different
so that's not a bad thing I just want to
make sure you're not compromising any
level of yourself and how you'd normally
be in a relationship that's not you
can't expect that because that's what
relationships are of course I'm gonna be
compromising
well what I'm saying there is that yes
relationships are about compromise in
some ways but you probably shouldn't
have to compromise your fundamental
lifestyle choices you know that's gonna
be tough
tell me what you guys think I do think
that Peters caught up a bit here in some
ideals that we are all brought up with
freezes like relationships are hard and
opposites attract I don't think people
have to be exactly the same and it's
good for your partner to push and
challenge you to be different and to
grow into a better version of yourself
but if you're talking about stuff like
faith and family
these are big things you know if you're
talking about lifestyle choices
I loved how barb was just like Madison
Peter parties
she's like Madison he drinks and he
loves to line dance we all know that he
comes from from a trip Madison you're at
church Peters at the country-western bar
and those are two different places
yeah I'm saying okay so they are on
different pages aren't they and Madison
did acknowledge that I appreciated this
about Madison she straight-up said I've
realized after this we are on totally
different pages and we kind of saw the
writing of those pages on the wall at
that point didn't waste so cheers to
Madison for seeing it oh so Peter says
goodbye to Madison from the date with
his parents and he's saying what we've
heard several leads say before I think
he keeps kind of saying look my parents
don't know her like I do they've just
met her today I've been dating her for
two months on the one hand fair on the
other hand this is a big moment
somebody's supposed to really reveal who
they are to your family and really
impress your family and Peter if you're
this close with your family and you
trust and love them this much you gotta
hear what they're saying I think let me
know in the comments below all right and
then everybody we get the big moments we
finally learned the big reveal we become
aware of who barb
is crying about did you expect it to be
Hanahan take a listen you know in loves
you with Oliver I go don't let her go
home we're home to us we will welcome
her with open arms you bring her home
bring her home to us we welcome her with
open arms so glad I got to add on to
that monologue I had to do it one more
time the doing it all season you guys
and oh did you think it was going to be
Hannah Ann I had some of you asking did
what was your prediction for who it
would be I truly didn't have one I I was
unclear because they've given us little
bits like Barb talking about God's plan
which will kind of indicate religion
Madison but no Bart was talking about
God's playing with Hannah and she said
she prayed and God said is Hannah Han
right there and Bart was so clear wasn't
she I mean she was crystal yeah so barb
wants Hannah Hannah at home to be her
daughter and to live with the family
forever and they'll welcome her with
open arms into the plan of God and down
the river yeah and then we still don't
know exactly how Peter feels he was kind
of telling mom look you're pushing too
hard and he's gonna hang out with the
ladies one more time so Peter goes
staying with Madison
we know how she's been feeling he bored
her what he said with sparkling apple
juice and I thought that was interesting
wasn't it again
they've never flat-out said it but we've
seen Hannah or we've seen Madison's
family toast with cider and now we're
seeing sparkling apple juice I'm not
sure that Madison drinks and I've said
this before I don't think this is a you
know there's no judgment on it and I do
think Madison seems worried she's gonna
be judged
look your life is your life I'm just
saying you got to be on the same page
about the person to spend that life with
and you know if Peter set the at the bar
line dancing and drinking do you want to
be there Madison that's a question
all right so Madison I have to applaud
her takes the writing off the wall and
speaks
from her lips she breaks up with Peter
and Peter didn't react as crazy strong
as I thought he would but I do want to
say let's go ahead and drink for all of
their painful hoes drink every time they
had a painful hug this is not cider it's
sure not okay so Madison breaks up with
Peter were you shocked let me know in
the comments below and then we find out
the headline Peter so much to process
Hannah and Peter meet up you guys
correct me if I'm wrong I don't Anna
didn't know right then Madison had
broken up with Peter so Hannah still
doesn't know and she's just speaking of
Peter so earnestly and I want to raise
my glass to Peter because he was kind of
still going in there and just treating
her on an even level and just trying to
make it about her and she's like I need
something and then we get the trailer
and we find out that Madison has regrets
and we find out that we still don't know
why Peter almost passed out that woman's
still coming we got barb crying we still
don't know why Peter almost passed out
in that bed we see a quick shot of
producer Julie la placa in the
background
I think that's kind of a red herring but
anyway that's right phrase red herring
I'm Miss nomer missed it anyway and Barb
is going to cry again yes yes yes
everybody we are going to get even more
tomorrow night on part 2 of the live
finale of The Bachelor and we will be
live again right here at 7:00 p.m.
Pacific so do not miss it let me know
everything that you're thinking we are
processing it all and I have just a bit
of champagne left so I'm gonna say bye
[Music]